- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk a little bit about
polynomial identities,
and this is really just a fancy way
of seeing whether an expression
that involves a polynomial is
equal to another expression.
So for example, you're familiar
with x squared plus two x plus one,
we've seen polynomials
like this multiple times,
this is a quadratic,
and you might recognize
that this would be equal
to x plus one squared,
that for any value of x,
x squared plus two x plus one
is the same thing as adding one to that x,
and then squaring the whole thing.
And we saw this when we first got,
when we first learned
how to multiply binomials
and we took the square of binomials,
but now we're going to do this
with slightly complicated expressions,
things that aren't just simple quadratics
or that might not be as obvious as this.
And the way that we're gonna
prove whether they are true
or not is just with a little
bit of algebraic manipulation.
So for example, if someone
walked up to you on the street
and said, all right, m
to the third minus one,
is it equal to m minus one
times one plus m plus m squared?
Pause this video and see what
you would tell that person,
whether you could prove whether it is
or is not a true polynomial identity.
Okay, let's do it together,
and the way I would tackle
this is I would expand out,
I would multiply out what we
have on the right-hand side,
so this is going to be equal to,
so first, I could take this m
and then multiply it times every term
in this second expression,
so m times one is m, m
times m is m squared,
and then m times m squared
is m to the third power,
and then I would take this negative one,
and then multiply and then
distribute that times every term
in that other expression,
so negative one times one is negative one,
negative one times m is negative m,
and negative one times m
squared is negative m squared,
and now let's see if we can simplify this.
We have an m and a negative m,
so those are going to cancel out,
we have an m squared and
a negative m squared,
so those cancel out, and so we are
going to be left with m to
the third power, minus one.
Now, clearly, m to the
third power minus one is
going to be equal to m to the third power
minus one for any value of m,
these are identical expressions.
So this is, this is indeed
a polynomial identity.
Let's do another example.
Let's say someone were to
walk up to you on the street
and said, quick, n plus
three squared plus two n,
is that equal to eight n plus 13,
is this a polynomial identity?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now we're gonna
work on that together.
And I would do it the exact same way.
I would try to simplify with
a little bit of algebra,
maybe the easiest thing to do first,
and you could do this in multiple ways is,
I have this, I have these n terms,
two n's here, eight n's over here,
well, what if I were to
get these two n's out
of the left-hand side, so if I were
to just subtract two n from
both sides of this equation,
I'm going to get on the left-hand side,
n plus three squared, and
on the right-hand side,
I'm going to get six n,
eight n minus two n, plus 13.
Now, what's n plus three squared?
Well, that's going to be n squared
plus two times three times n.
And if what I just did does
not seem familiar to you,
I encourage you to look
at the videos about squaring binomials,
but this is going to be plus six n,
plus three squared, which is nine,
and is this going to be
equal to six n plus 13?
Well, already this is
starting to look a little bit,
a little bit sketchy, but let's
just keep going with the algebra.
So let's see if we subtract six n
from both sides, what do you get?
Well, on the left-hand side,
you're just going to
have n squared plus nine,
and on the right-hand side,
you're going to get 13.
Now, are there values of n for
which this is not always true?
Well, sure.
I can find a lot of values of n for
which this is not always true.
If n is a zero, this is
not going to be true.
If n is one, this is not going to be true.
If n is two, this actually would be true,
but if n is three, this
is not going to be true.
If n is four, five, et cetera,
so for actually most values of n,
this is not going to be true.
So in order for it to be
a polynomial identity,
it has to be true for all of the values
that are legitimate values that
you can evaluate for those,
for the variable in question.
So this one right over
here is not a polynomial,
polynomial identity, and we are done.